welcome back to New Rockstars it's me MD
and wakanda forever just changed what we
knew to be true about mutants in the MCU
by introducing us to how the Telecom
people turned blue and made a baby that
flew and breathed in the ocean too I'm
counting for that ass Dr Seuss
when Neymar's Origins were shown on the
big screen alongside the origins of the
telecon people of the sea Neymar
mentions that he was in fact a mutant
officially adding name or the Submariner
as the newest confirmed mutant on the
Block in the MCU but what exactly makes
name more a mutant in this universe I
think wakanda forever might actually
hold a hint as to what might be a key
ingredient to the MCU Secrets mutant
formula so let's dive into it together
my nerd babies because I think I have
found the main Cosmic factor that links
mutant cousins Namor and Kamala Khan
together but before we continue I need
you guys to know that I always keep that
[ __ ] thing on me and by that
[ __ ] thing I mean wow my
Panther on my chest which you can get to
at new rockstarsmerch.com as part of our
latest Obsession series because we got
shirts inspired by wakanda forever over
there alright so what exactly could make
a name or a mutant in the MCU well
obviously a huge chunk of it has to do
with the strange blue flowing vibranium
plant that the ancient people of Yucatan
ingested before they all got so sick
that they turned blue in the face and
lost the ability to breathe on land as
well as the one woman among them that
was already pregnant with the boy that
would become known as Neymar which he
was convinced to drink that
life-changing blue Powerade but first
let's talk about that weird vibranium
plant that one of Neymar's ancestors was
guided and directed to in a Divine
Vision much like the first black panther
and ruler of wakanda bashango was
initially led to the heart-shaped herb
by a vision from bass so we see those
parallels there I strongly believe the
main reason why shuri was able to use
Neymar's plant to synthesize a
heart-shaped herb is because of the blue
cosmic energy that radiates from
deposits of vibranium because this is
the same blue energy that mutated Neymar
in the womb when namor's mother first
drank that plant juice all the way back
in the 1500s and I believe it's the very
same type of blue energy that was living
inside of Kamala Khan her entire life
until those bracelets Drew out that blue
energy from within her body energy that
the clandestines called nor energy but
as we learned from Miss Marvel that's
just a label this blue energy my nerd
babies is a little something called Dark
Energy on planet Earth and it was the
main focus of Nick Fury Marvel Howard
Stark and Tony Stark's professional
careers as most of them studied the dark
energy Mysteries of the blue Tesseract
at the Joint Dark Energy Mission
facility at Project Pegasus before Eno
Loki caused the place to come a tumbling
down at the beginning of Avengers 1.
Howard Stark spent his entire life
studying the dark energy in the
Tesseract to find that new element for
Tony to use in his blue arc reactors and
Marvel used the dark energy in the
Tesseract to construct her Lightspeed
engine that would give Captain Marvel
her blue powers and dark energy is
actually a real science thing that
Marvel Studios has adapted for their
films ever since 2008 because you see
Dark Energy accounts for about 68 of the
entire universe it's the reason why
space keeps expanding and the universe
keeps getting bigger and bigger by the
second so basically this Cosmic stuff is
around us at all times in real life
which is why Marvel Studios made the
space Stone space a stone of dark energy
because Dark Energy creates space and is
everywhere in space I'm going somewhere
with this please hold on
we're like
talking
but it's cold
that was evolved to detect light and
because of that it's an energy that
science has struggled to understand
because we can't freaking see it because
our eyes are so stupid literally what
Marvel Studios has done for the past
what however long they've been around is
ask the question what would happen if a
huge chunk of vibranium the most energy
absorptive metal material known to
Marvel man crash landed on Earth after
God knows how many millions of years
traveling across the universe crashing
into and absorbing all the dark energy
in its path in space what would happen
because vibranium absorbs energy like a
[ __ ] and the answer to that what
would happen question is Marvel's
Marvels start happening especially when
some of that blue vibranium Dark Energy
radiation starts leaking into the plant
life and enriching the Earth's plants
with unseen cosmic power much like the
radiation of the Tesseract transformed
Carol Danvers physiology to make her go
higher further and faster than ever
before today's video is sponsored by
Wonder you know how when you have an
idea for something awesome your brain
goes whoa that's awesome but then
sometimes you sit down and draw your
awesome idea and your hands refuse to be
as awesome as the drawing in your brain
come on hands get with the program well
if you get Wonder those pesky hands of
yours won't get in the way of your
awesome brain ideas Wonder turns
ordinary text prompts into incredible
pieces of art using Cutting Edge AI it's
like having an assistant who's a
phenomenal artist that lives to create
the stuff that you want to see I've been
having fun finding small moments with
superheroes like Batman doing laundry
Captain America at Burger King or Doctor
Strange on a bicycle or I don't know
whatever you want to see since getting
the app I have spent hours turning every
whim in my weird brain into an image
that I can share with my friends it's
great wonder is a free download but if
you upgrade to premium you'll have no
ads unlimited art faster load times and
over 20 additional styles that use click
the link in the description box below
for a free trial but anyways this all
being said another important thing to
remember here is that Neymar's mother
was already well on her way into her
pregnancy when she introduced this
cosmically irradiated plant into her
system this means that Neymar was
already pretty much at least a half
developed human male right before then
by drinking this vibranium juice Mama
Neymar's genetic makeup completely
mutated making Namor half mer man from
his mother's side but still half human
from his father's side because his
father's genetic material that Neymar
started developing with was 100 fully
human so this being the case if you look
at this all from the standpoint of the C
great energy narrative that Kevin feige
and friends have been telling us for
over a decade Neymar essentially has a
very similar genetic situation to Kamala
Khan because Kamala herself is a human
on her father's side but filled with
that dark energy nor that populated her
clandestine ancestors home Universe this
is what makes Neymar and Kamala mutants
being a human being with mutated
genetics like the regular blue citizens
of talocon would not be considered
mutants despite having originally been
Homo Sapien because they are no longer
human beings and in all honesty if you
kind of think about it they all sort of
devolved in a way instead of evolving
like a mutant would because if you
really think about it Evolution was all
about early sea creatures evolving and
being able to walk on land but the
people living in Yucatan lost that homo
sapien status entirely when they
completely changed their DNA and they
lost their ability to breathe air and
walk on land that's sort of a
de-evolution of sorts Neymar is a mutant
because he's the only one amongst his
people that is actually is a human
mutant but a human that has been blessed
with just the right amount of cosmic
energy to trigger a human evolution and
become more to be able to do marvelous
things like go higher further and faster
like Carol Danvers this is what I
strongly believe will be a huge reason
why Marvel Studios has decided to start
the mutant story with Miss Marvel and
continue that story with the Captain
Marvel sequel the Marvels because each
one of those women on the Marvel's team
has access to that blue space Stone
Singularity dark energy that allows them
to do marvelous things so if you're
wondering when we might see name or next
the Marvels could be a very safe bet I
bet but anyways thank you guys so much
for watching this video you can follow
me at mastertainment on Twitter if you
want to see me tweets and weird [ __ ] but
more importantly you could follow new
rockstars wherever we are on social
media and do not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmarch.com to pick up one of
these
amazing black panther wakanda forever
shirts but again thank you guys so much
for watching this video I love you guys
times a million I'll see you guys next
time goodbye
goodbye
[Music]